so jordan is one of the great thinkers
of our time but i would say the greatest
thinkers of our time is michael malus
you've also got the chat yeah uh
well so he wrote a book on north
it's korea interesting style book i
learned a lot from it i learned a lot
from michael about it
and it's interesting that he chose
north korea as a as a thing to study
that he of all people this fascinating
human being that is michael
chose this darkest of aspects of
of uh humanity to study what uh
what do you think of michael what do you
think of his book on north korea called
deer reader that people should
definitely check out
absolutely so back then when i reached
out
michael threw a mutual friend in south
korea i my english wasn't good
so i got a copy in my hand i tried to
read
and a lot of them i didn't understand so
but i thought it was very fascinating
how he explained north korea through the
deal leaders perspective
right as nobody has ever done that and
you can revere so much about the state
and the absurdity of entire situation
and also through humor and that's what's
amazing about my chris
is he knows the full gravity of tragedy
he knows the full suffering he's not
just like people here in america
on the bus feed making fun of kim jones
haircut they don't care what people go
through
michael cares deeply cares and then he
still does ridiculous jokes
so that that kind of reveals in a dark
way the absurdity
yeah of evil yeah he does that
masterfully do you
he's a genius he is definitely all right
let's
let's if he watches this uh then
you know let's not get make his head too
big here um
but is there some aspect to
i mean there is an absurdity to the
whole thing
kim jong-un is this i mean it's almost
like a caricature of evil
like joke it's a joke a lot of people
think it's a joke
they just think like this is too too
absurd they just
they laugh like can you imagine you
laugh at holocaust this is
that ridiculous can you maybe
psychoanalyze that a little bit because
that that's where my mind goes too like
he's so ridiculous
that you can't it's almost like hard to
believe this is real
is that just is that just my kind of and
people's
desire to escape the cruelty of reality
by just kind of making a joke out of it
i think
it is a few things right like um
to north korea as a nation uh number one
or number two smartest iq people in the
world
despite their magnitude so
so so there's i mean that that wasn't
that's an interesting point so
yeah in your sense the people are not
dumb
still carry the the brilliance there's a
there's a culture there that's like
hungry to
become realized like the people that
that were
like that that are silenced by the
electricity by the
actually having no food all those kinds
of things like if you add the
electricity if you add
the food you're going to have a cultural
center of the world like south korea
that's what they exactly did right the
exact same korea
one became more like 11th largest
economy
one became the world's most like polish
nation
right and this is the perfect example
like if i don't know if you read the
book why
nation affairs the system
it's not about the culture it is not
about people it's not about you
what makes us too different is a system
south korea is north korea is a perfect
example of that
one is exact same capability we are
homogeneous like country
same language tradition all of that we
gave them different systems
one is free democracy one dictatorship
and
came up with the biggest different
result and i think
north korea reveres that to us it's not
because we are great that we are living
in this prosperity free market
the ideas gave us to this the system we
built
our ancestors spirit gave us this
privilege
it's not us nothing is about us being
special here right
the system that we have is quite special
and north korea proves that to us it
doesn't matter even if you're smart
it that's all irrelevant and i think
that's why
people just keep denying that they want
to feel special like because
i'm awesome i got all of this like no
it's not you you got this
and when people say like i hate
capitalism it's like
without capitalism how do you came up
with this thing
literally how did you come up with this
the systems
matter and they matter like
um way more than this individualistic
society
would like to imagine
it is the most important thing you can
have in life choosing the right system
you